اداره الطيران الفيدراليه قالت ان خلل
اصاب نظام اشعار الرحلات الجويه ما دفعها
الى تعليق جميع الرحلات المحليه في
الولايات المتحده قرار تعليق الملاحه
الجويه اجبر شركات الطيران الامريكيه على
تاخير الاف رحلات الجويه فضلا عن الغاء
اخرى
وعن سبب العطل الذي ادى الى اصابه حركه
الطيران بشلل في الولايات المتحده لساعات
استبعد البيت الابيض فرضيه الهجوم
السيبراني واوضح ان الرئيس جوبيد امر بفتح
تحقيق
تحدثت للتو مع وزير النقل ولا يعرفنا بعد
سبب العطل لكنني كنت معهم عبر الهاتف
وطالبتهم بابلاغي فور الكشف عن السبب نظام
اشعار الرحلات الجويه التي اصابه العطل
مخصص لابلاغ الطيران بحالات الطوارئ
وبمعلومات تتعلق بسلامه عمليات الملاحه
الجويه
ووفقه اداره الطيران الفيدراليه تعرض نظام
الاشعار لعطل فني خلال ساعات الليل قبل ان
يعود الى العمل عند الساعه 9:00 صباحا
بتوقيت الساحل الشرقي الامريكي ليسمح
باستئناف الرحلات الجويه تدريجيا
تعطل حركه الطائرات المدنيه المحليه في
الولايات المتحده يثير تساؤلات عن سلامه
وكفاءه الانظمه الفيدراليه المعنيه بتنظيم
الملاحه الجويه في ظل تعهد الكونغرس
بالتحقيق في الاسباب فادي منصور الجزيره
من امام مطار ريجن في العاصمه واشنطن